andrew heaney the veteran lefty
gonna give it a go against the red sox
you see on the year the numbers 37 walks
131 strikeouts so 24 home runs is what
stands out and a little bit more in our
picture scouting report that really what
is what it's all about he needs a good
one and the big fly watch because he's
given up eight home runs in 15 innings
as a yankee and the way he gets out of
that is get that fastball life back he
pitches off of his fastball it's kind of
sneaky quick it's got a little life to
it a little riding action if he's
getting late swings he's got a chance on
the year bogots at 307 and against genie
he actually is sitting one at-bat better
than 500. he's
13. and he swings and drives one in the
air to right field down the line toward
the corner will they go yes second deck
home runs xander bogarts one-nothing
boston
his 19th of the year is 67th rbi ander
bogarts continues to own
andrew heeney's now eight for 14 with
two doubles two homers and four rbis
i would say he's properly rated that is
such a big big swing for xander and the
red sox i feel like maybe everybody can
just take a deep breath it'll loosen
everybody up a little bit and the righty
nick pavetta gonna make his 24 start
here in the bronx tonight
and all those numbers right there pretty
solidly above average when you look at
them and
as we're going to tell you in the
scouting report yeah it is a solid year
a lot of different ways to slice it and
dice it his 53.3 game score for a
starting pitcher is solidly above
average about 50 to 51 is considered
average and he's well supported and the
team record is 15-8 and his games
averaging almost six runs well here is
anthony rizzo back in the lineup the
rizz he's at 2 51 17 home with 46 rbis
swung on and hit in the air softly to
left center on the run
good catch by renfro took a while to get
over there roduko is converging going to
his left right throw to his right but he
made the catch giancarlo stanton leads
off the bottom of the second inning
yankees trail one nothing and the
bitch's line there's a base in the left
here though stanton
singles there's the trying run at first
with no one out seeing stanton and judge
both covering that breaking ball during
this run both of them swinging the bat
much better covering the breaking ball
late in the count much better judge
hitting him to right stand staying
through that ball hammering in the ball
to the left so the yankees have
something going in the second inning a
single and a walk
fly ball shallow right coming on
martinez
and he can't make the play
hustling to second
and he's out yankees are challenging
looks like he's safe look his hand is on
the base before the ball was in the
glove so
yanks have the bases loaded no one out
for gardner velasquez and la mayhew fly
ball
center field this will get in stanton
renfro makes the catch stanton tags and
goes the throw comes to third the other
runners stay it's a sack fly for gardner
and that ties the game at one now here's
andrew velasquez a switch into batting
left vazquez and the yankee 5-3 win in
game one of the doubleheader velasquez
had a two-run single get on the ground
tour the middle basic great center field
here comes odor he'll score head injured
third is sanchez it's a base hit and an
rbi for andrew velasquez the yankees
take a 2-1 lead
and susan one thing
if velasquez is going to get base hits
he's going to be playing a lot of
shortstop because his shortstopping is
great everything he doesn't and this kid
talk about i mean we keep saying it
every day now he's getting instructions
from reggie willits because he can
really steal him he can really run
runners at second and third infield
moves back for the left-hand hitter
anthony rizzo grounded to first and off
the glove of daldock rolling down the
right field line one round scores two
runs for velasquez bobby dalbeck could
not field it cleanly and now it's four
to one yankees
well it was up a breaking pitch that was
up and he got underneath it you could
see that
but it is a two-run single and what
happened it hit the line and off of
dalbeck's glove
so they give russo a base hit it's a
two-run base hit for anthony yanks take
a 4-1 lead third for genie martinez here
the red sox took it's only the fourth
inning even just getting that one run
home would be a big
help for the red sox chances in this
game swung on hit on the ground wide of
third grabbed beautifully by odor throws
the first in time beautiful play he
saved a run what devers did in the top
half or the bottom half of last inning
well that's just what uh odor did cut
off a base hit in the shortstop hole
here's right hand hitting bobby dolback
one on and one out top of the fifth 4-1
yang and the bitch's line grabbed by
lemay you what a leap
lemay who
[Music]
waited
timed it and jumped as high as he could
and got the line drive in the top of his
glove a terrific play
obviously by far he needs best game as a
yank xander bogart's homered and then
hit into a force one on one out we're in
the top of the sixth phobos hits a one
hop and a third double play ball go to
second one on the first it's a double
play
it's a five four three double play
and indeed miss tahini gets through six
innings beautifully tahini has pitched
by far the best game he's pitched as a
yank two down in the seventh
popped him up
shallow center gardner in gardiner makes
the catch and a one two three inning for
andrew haney
absolutely brilliant 108 pitches and
just two hits and that one home run off
the bat of bogors in the first inning so
here is britain as boy is this big for
the yankees isn't it susan
if britain can
pitch like the old zach britain that's
what they're looking for
left-hand hitting alex verdugo is in
swing
miss that's that's an important number
when you see his fastball at 95.
his first pitch of that account was 96
and i don't think we've seen that since
he's been back and this is a good
two-seamer at 95. this is the one you
look up there was so much movement it
almost looked like a curveball oh two
down here is andrew velasquez it shortly
basically another ribby for velasquez
scoring is sanchez and the yankees lead
for ribbies
for velasquez in the last couple of days
he had three in his entire major league
career a four-run deficit top of the
order hernandez renfro and bogarts
that'll be up against aurelius chapman
who has just returned there's a swing at
a high drive to deep left field this is
long gone home run hunter renfrew way
back into the bleachers he got a
fastball on the inside he really nailed
it
under renfro with a tremendous home run
he's 22nd of the year and it's 5-2
yankees there's xander now homer back in
the first and he bounced another one
ball four bounced the slider and here is
a really great hitter jd martinez line
to right field there's a base in the run
won't score
judge gets it on a hob and fires in
that's going to bring up plawecki as the
tying run and plawecki is not facing
chapman so it could be lipke
against plawecki with the game on the
line grounded in the hole
diving stock velasquez
gets him at first
it got past the diving door somehow
velasquez made the play they don't need
any stinking laughers they just win
close games